[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here so period
cravings some of us have severe cravings
during PMS others may experience it
during the actual period and the lucky
ones do not have cravings at all well I
personally crave for reach creamy food
like ice cream one week leading up to my
period
do you have any cravings and if so what
are your cravings our body and hormones
artifical and can be tricky to
understand especially this special time
of the month for this video I will be
focusing on food cravings and tips to do
with it
so what are some of the common period
cravings and why first sugar and carbs
it is very common for us to crave for
sugars and high carbohydrate foods like
pasta bread and rice before and during
period these cravings are often sign of
low serotonin levels and low blood sugar
levels sorry Tony
is the feel-good chemical in our brain
hence when levels are low we crave for
sugars and carbs that's because our body
uses carbs to produce serotonin second
is chocolate chocolate is one of the top
cravings it tastes good it makes you
feel good it is connected to positive
emotions and love hence a comfort food
to many of us if you crave for chocolate
before and during your period it can
also be that you are lacking in
magnesium and iron chocolate contains
both magnesium and iron hence that is
why we desire it even more the common
cravings ice creams or rich desserts
research has shown that before and
during period we may also experience low
level of calcium hence we tend to crave
for reached food that has high calcium
such as ice creams cakes or any other
rich desserts
I am definitely in this category I love
ice creams but I tend to crave for them
even more leading up to my period I
not going to tell you to avoid your
cravings because it is not going to help
and we may end our binging instead let's
explore some tips that can help you with
your food cravings if you're someone
that craves for high carb foods I would
encourage you to consume meals and
snacks which are high in complex carbs
such as whole-grain bread potato brown
rice bananas beans other fruits and
vegetables have them for breakfast
because these high-fiber foods will take
much longer for your body to digest
hence it will help to control cravings
throughout the day and if you have
complex carbs on an empty stomach it
will have to increase serotonin levels
within an hour so
no more graphic days ahead sugar
cravings when your blood sugar level is
low you crave for sweets and so you have
it this will then increase your blood
sugar level but only for a short while
you will end up wanting more sugary food
and drinks and that is why some of us
can be addicted to sugars have you
experienced this before to break this
cycle go for food that contains natural
sugars such as fruits juices honey
yogurt and carbs consuming these foods
with complex carbs will help you to
balance your blood sugar level and to
reduce cravings if you're someone that
experienced magnesium and iron
deficiency while the good news is you
can give in to your chocolate cravings
chocolates are high in magnesium and
iron but also high in fat so try to
choose high-quality antioxidant rich
dark chocolate over milk chocolate which
typically has more calories and fat or
you can have a cup of hot chocolate and
remember to consume in moderation other
high iron and magnesium foods include
beans seeds nuts green vegetables fish
and red meat so if you are looking for
an excuse to consume red meat this is
the perfect time a nice lean piece of
red meat can help to increase iron and
also to make up for what's lost each
month magnesium can also have to
decrease common Mastro symptoms such as
blue
ting constipation headaches anxiety or
swollen breasts so do increase your
magnesium and iron intakes tip for
calcium calcium has been shown to help
with PMS a woman who has a diet high in
calcium tend to experience less bloating
cramping or mood swings during and
before periods and this can also help
you if you do experience irregular
periods foods high in calcium include
milk yogurt dairy products or green
leafy vegetables this next tip is really
important practice mindful eating
we all have cravings and to avoid them
completely will only make you worse and
so if you want a piece of chocolate cake
or ice cream go ahead and have it I am
NOT going to say no only one requirement
it's in a mindful way when you are aware
and present with the food you are
craving for you will feel satisfied with
less and sometimes you may even realize
that this is not what your body needs
and so when you indulge in your cravings
be mindful and keep portion in chat one
muffin will not ruin your diet
several muffins will next tip exercising
any physical activities from running to
doing home exercises basically anything
that keeps your heart pumping will
increase serotonin levels and to reduce
stress levels plus when you sweat you
will get rid of excess water and to
reduce bloating it does not have to be a
long workout session even a shot
10-minute walk will help to boost your
mood and to reduce cravings
this can include walking your dog
gardening doing house works basically
just keep moving hence that is why some
people tend to turn to doing house
chores when they are stressed because
moving helps and if you're someone that
experienced severe cramps and bloating
and you can't do your regular exercises
then tend to gentle mind-body exercises
such as yoga or Tai Chi it will help to
calm you down
reduce cramps bloating and to keep you
on track with your fitness the final tip
sunshine and relax
like all sunshine can reduce our
feel-good hormones which will lead to
increase in appetite and cravings
hence Venice wife some of us may
experience seasonal affective disorder
over the winter period and we tend to
eat more as well so go outdoor get the
sunshine eat increase your serotonin
levels and reduce cravings cravings can
be worsened in types of stress in our
busy schedule it is very easy to pop a
pill and push through without giving our
body the chance to truly rest and relax
more than ever this is the time where
you should allow your mind and body to
relax pamper yourself do an activity you
enjoy or sometimes what we need is to do
absolutely nothing these are seven
simple tips which can help to reduce
period cravings on the flip side here
are three foods to limit first caffeine
too much of caffeine can cause
irritability stress nervousness which
can potentially lead to food cravings
and worsen menstrual cramps second salt
because it causes water retention and
bloating third alcohol because it can
act as depressant and worsen PMS
symptoms it is important to know that we
are all different and that the cravings
and symptoms may or may not apply to you
therefore during this special time of
the month it is very important to listen
to your body fill your body with good
food keep moving keep yourself hydrated
and rest when you need to your body
knows best so listen to it for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
[Music]
you